servietten damen und herren einen
schönen guten morgen wobei schön ein
relativer begriff ist und ich hoffe das
nächtliche pressekonferenzen mit diesem
podium
nachts um zwei nicht zu einer routine
erstarrt werden sie interessiert
natürlich die vorgänger des heutigen
abends und aus diesem grund möchte
polizeivizepräsident deiner pfeiler
unserer polizeipräsident robertos andré
ihnen jetzt den neuesten stand zu den
vorfällen der letzten acht stunden geben
meine damen und herren
der gestrige tag war zweifelsohne mein
schwerster tage meiner amtszeit als
münchner polizeipräsident und einer der
schwersten tage überhaupt in einer
dienstlichen laufbahn vor mehr als 40
jahren das geschehen von gestern abend
und heute macht macht uns traurig
sprachlos und die gedanken sind
insbesondere jetzt auch bei den opfern
das drama nahm um gegen 1750 seinen
anfang als uns aus dem bereich des osz
im westen von münchen eine schießerei
gemeldet wurde
aufgrund von zeugenaussagen mussten wir
zunächst von bis zu drei tätern ausgehen
zwei personen die den tatort mit einem
fahrzeug und sehr hoher geschwindigkeit
verlassen hatten und somit in den praxis
der tatverdächtigen kommen konnten
zwischenzeitlich ermittelt werden
abgeklärt werden sie haben mit der sache
nichts zu tun
die bevölkerung wurde von uns
aufgefordert
wo immer es möglich ist im haus zu
bleiben
der öffentliche nahverkehr im
stadtgebiet unter s bahn verkehr auf der
stammstrecke wurden eingestellt weil uns
immer wieder aus dem stadtgebiet
angebliche schießereien gemeldet wurden
zwischenzeitlich haben wir den betrieb
des öffentlichen personennahverkehrs ab
0 1 uhr wieder freigegeben
und wir gehen davon aus dass ab 04 uhr
die entsprechenden regel fahrpläne
wieder im einsatz sind
im zuge der fahndung mit starken kräften
wurde gegen 20 uhr 30 eine männliche
person aufgefunden die nach dem jetzigen
stand der ermittlungen suizid verübt
hatte aufgrund von zeugenaussagen und
der auswertung von videomaterial gehen
wir davon aus dass es sich um den
gesuchten tatverdächtigen handelt
hinweise dass weitere personen an der
tat beteiligt waren liegen derzeit nicht
vor
haben die ermittlungen bisher nicht
ergeben
der tatverdächtige ist nach dem
derzeitigen ermittlungsstand ein 18
jähriger deutsch iraner aus münchen
im zuge der fahndung hatten denn eine
zivilstreife in der anfangsphase kontakt
zum täter hat diesen auch beschlossen wo
wir dabei getroffen wurde muss jetzt die
obduktion ergeben
insgesamt haben wir derzeit die traurige
bilanz von zehn toten
inklusive des tatverdächtigen verletzte
wurden 21 fahrten in die krankenhäuser
durchgeführt wobei derzeit noch 16
verletzte davon drei schwer verletzte
und 13 leicht verletzte in kliniken
behandelt werden
motiv und hintergrund der tat sind noch
völlig unklar die ermittlungen laufen
natürlich auch während der nacht auf
hochtouren der tat am tatort ist
weiträumig abgesperrt wird es auch in
den nächsten stunden zu bleiben und die
spurensicherung wird dann bei tageslicht
fortgeführt insgesamt waren in diesem
einsatz
circa 2.300 einsatzkräfte eingesetzt
darunter unterstützungskräfte aus der
gsg 9
den sondereinsatz kommandos baden
württemberg und hessen der cobra aus
österreich hefte aus anderen
polizeipräsident bayern der
bereitschaftspolizei des
landeskriminalamtes der bayerischen
bereitschaftspolizei und der
hubschrauber stoffe bei der evakuierung
haben wir insbesondere darauf geachtet
dass der grundsatz gilt sicherheit vor
schnelligkeit deshalb haben sich diese
maßnahmen auch über einen längeren
zeitraum hingezogen und die bitte an
dieser stelle die betroffenen um
nachsicht
aber uns war ihre sicherheit eben
besonders wichtig im laufe des einsatzes
erhielten wir zahlreiche notrufe und
hinweise auf angebliche schießereien
oder geiselnahmen diese mitteilungen und
meldungen haben zu einer massiven
verunsicherung der bevölkerung geführt
alle hinweise haben wir sofort
entsprechend abgeklärt
gott sei dank hat sich keiner dieser
hinweise bestätigt
circa 100 personen haben auch im
polizeipräsidium münchen hier schutz
gesucht
im stadtgebiet wurden verschiedene
veranstaltungen abgesagt und natürlich
standen wir in einem engen
informationsaustausch auch mit den
stadtverantwortlichen für die morgigen
veranstaltungen besteht aus
sicherheitsgründen kein absage grund wo
wir die veranstalter gegebenenfalls aus
pietätsgründen die ein oder andere
veranstaltung absagen ist dann sozusagen
den veranstaltern überlassen
soweit der aktuelle sachstand der
aktuelle bericht
und wie gesagt die weiteren maßnahmen
sind jetzt insbesondere die
spurensicherung die spurensuche an dem
großen tatort das wird dann sicherlich
noch einige stunden dann hier
an kräften binden und einige stunden
soweit fragen sind plötzlich
gut der erste abend schnellt in die höhe
zu den fragen wäre meine bitte
tatsächlich beschränken sie sich
zunächst einmal den ersten auf eine
frage pro anwesenden wir können das dann
im weiteren kern aufbohren bitteschön
ihre erste frage wie bereits jetzt
berichtet hat ist auch da die ursache
darin dass eben angeblich schüsse zu
hören waren und dann leute eben
schreiend weggelaufen sind
das war ein auslöser für diese situation
immer am stachus und die abklärungen
haben ergeben aber das ist wie in allen
anderen fällen eben kein die ursache
dafür keine veranlassung dafür gab
münchen in münchen gelebt und vielleicht
noch ein bisschen umgehen um den ablauf
zu sparen davon dass der kontakt mit 7
der ablauf war nach unserem jetzigen
stand ich bitte aber das wirklich auch
zu respektieren und zu sehen wir sind ja
ganz erst am anfang der ermittlungen
weil bis zu dem zeitpunkt bis wir nicht
sicher waren dass sozusagen keine gefahr
mehr besteht konnten ja an den einzelnen
tatorten und geschehens werden keine
ermittlungen durchgeführt werden
hat also der ganze vorfall bei einem
schnellrestaurant begangen begonnen hat
sich dann in richtung dieses
einkaufszentrum verlagert und dann ist
der täter eben geflohenen innen fischer
erst phase hatte eben nach unseren
erkenntnissen eine zivilstreife kontakt
zum täter hat den täter geschossen
zu den hintergründen zur person müssen
wir auch jetzt zunächst einmal die
ganzen personen die ganzen aspekte
abklären bevor wir da jetzt auch
sozusagen konkrete auskünfte erteilen
können
natürlich wissen wir aus zumal auch kein
geheimnis aus dem polizei liegen dateien
entsprechende erkenntnisse aber alles
muss also hier überprüft werden und
geklärt werden so dass man dort sicher
sozusagen das dann sagen können wenn das
geschehen ist
die person hat schon länger in münchen
gelegt so wie sie klopft an länger
naja wenn das länger ist für sie mehr zu
längerem angebot
august in einer zeitung die behandlung
es kann ich momentan nicht bestätigen
das ist jetzt auch sache der
kriminalpolizeiliche ermittlungen allein
auf diese aussage hinkommen das nicht
bestätigen
der renter person war bisher polizeilich
nicht bekannt
können sie was zum thema sagen wir
vorgang ist wirklich erwache ich
hervorgegangen wo hat er menschen
erschossen und ist ungefähr abgelaufen
der ungefähre ablauf war so dass der
täter mit der schießerei im bereich
diese schneller ist damals begonnen hat
in dem schnellrestaurant geschossen hat
und anschließend dann sich in richtung
einkaufszentrum bewegt hat und dort die
schießerei fortgeführt hat und da sind
auch die entsprechenden opfer zu
beklagen
nein gibt es derzeit keine erkenntnisse
ursache der kriminalpolizeilichen
ermittlungen sein
was das motiv ist welche verbindung
welche kontakte ob die überhaupt gibt
und so weiter es muss alles erst jetzt
im grunde genommen zuge der ermittlungen
geklärt werden
weiter fragen mit
nach den ersten erkenntnissen handle
sich um eine pistole
alles andere ist jetzt momentan sache
der tatortarbeit
familie und welche beziehungen oder
welche personen rolle spielen
bitte um verständnis muss jetzt erst
ermittelt werden muss erst geklärt
nicht vorhalten ausklingt
wir haben derzeit überhaupt keine
anhaltspunkte dass tatsächlich eine
langwaffe zum einsatz kommen wir kennen
diese informationen haben aber bis jetzt
bei unseren ermittlungen dazu keine
erkenntnisse gewonnen
den rucksack der wurde aufgefunden
eine langwaffe drin auch nicht es gibt
ja relativ große magazine also waffen
mit großen magazinen und man kann
natürlich auch ohne dass dies jetzt in
irgendeiner form bestätigen rein
theoretisch kann natürlich auch während
der tat sozusagen ein magazin wechsel
erfolgen es kann ja auch ein nachlassen
der waffe erfolgen
das muss man dann sehen wie viel oft ja
eigentlich geschossen hat wenn man die
dort genau angeschaut hat die hülsen
entsprechend zuordnen kann dann weiß man
wie der täter griff der täter geschossen
das auto des anfang und das einsatz ist
eine rolle gespielt dort des arztes den
tatort sozusagen mit hoher
geschwindigkeit verlassen hatte
diese personen konnte neben ermittelt
werden diese sachverhalt konnte anke
jähriger hat mit der sache überhaupt
nichts zu tun
ansonsten nahm auch die bisherigen
fahndungsmaßnahmen über den jetzigen
erkenntnisstand hinaus nichts erbracht
zu den todesopfern bitte ich um
verständnis dass wir jetzt momentan
nicht sagen wollen weil wir jetzt gerade
dabei sind die identität der einzelnen
opfer sicher abzuklären und dann erst im
grunde genommen auch mit den angehörigen
hier die situation besprechen wollen
ihnen auch die entsprechende
todesnachricht überbringen müssen vorher
wollen wir zu den opfern bedingung
verständnis nicht sein zweites tor
fallen
der täter konnte dann seine flucht
fortsetzen
die kollegen haben ihn aus den augen
verloren und er konnte erst später
wieder aufgefunden werden
da bin ich jetzt über fragt ob die an
deutschen ausweis dabei gehabt hat das
ist jetzt auch gesagt frage der
kriminalpolizei die ermittlungen da muss
es dann auch die kleidung entsprechend
abgesucht werden
der ausweis eingesteckt habe das kann
ich ihnen jetzt
das komme abschließen die autos richtig
gut weiter fragen
als
er kann jetzt momentan in dieser erst
phase nur feststellen wann das begonnen
hat etwa 1750 und die fahndungskräfte
haben um 20 uhr 30
eben dann die läufer tätige person
aufgefunden
wenn wir das bestätigen oder im jahr
angehoben
also soll angeblich was gerufen haben
wir sind gerade dabei und habe mir auch
die bevölkerung dazu aufgerufen
videomaterial des entsprechend erstellt
wurde und das entsprechend produziert
wurde uns zur verfügung zu stellen
auch da ist jetzt sozusagen nach wenigen
stunden noch nicht sicher wer oder was
gerufen hat das muss man genau
analysieren sich das genau anschauen und
insofern kommen dass jetzt noch nicht
definitiv ausschließen aber auch nicht
bestätigen
schüler studenten
momentan konnte ich dort immer nicht
davon gehen wir momentan aus dass der
täter auf dem dach war mit einer anderen
person von einer anderen person gefilmt
wurde mit ihr kommuniziert hatte da habe
ich derzeit keine erkenntnisse
wir haben derzeit keine erkenntnisse
darüber dass dieser brutale und trage
gefallen
sozusagen dazu anlass gibt hier sich
unsicher zu fühlen
man muss aber auch ganz deutlich sagen
und das ist ja auch keine neue
erkenntnis dass es eine
hundertprozentige sicherheit nicht gibt
und auf der anderen seite eben wie
gesagt dass wir keinerlei erkennen sie
derzeit haben dass es anlass dafür gibt
sich unsicher zu fühlen oder irgendwo
sozusagen sich zu verkriechen
eine hundertprozentige sicherheit oder
sonstige verhandlungsweise von personen
kommen ja nie ausschließen
liga
vergleichbarkeit derzeit sehen wir keine
ähnlichkeiten